good morning Hank and John I'm Dave I'm
the operations manager at dftba this is
the rest of our staff this is Kanan the
warehouse manager hainan is the reason
we don't have a forklift in the
warehouse what's enabled northland well
of course it's for Quetelet pork this
this is Rachel she'd had a Creator
support she gets to deal with all her
wonderful videos on a daily basis she's
helped design many of our products and
this is Meg I had a customer service any
time you get an email it's probably
coming from Meg so the real reason we're
here today is to introduce you to the
person who created Pizza this this is
Valerie barking well hello Valerie
actually got your message
she works for VidCon but her claim to
fame and life and really this is her
lasting legacy is she designed Pizza
John yeah well so there is a long and
storied back history to the creation of
pizza John which led to Pizza miss Hank
actually did a video last year where he
explained the backstory list and that
link is down below but give us a 10
second version of pizza John well John
likes pizza one time in a video John had
a mustache does and here we are six
years later we created kind of our own
pizza miss Museum here and we're gonna
have Valerie take us on a tour through
the illustrious history of pizza nuts
you ready to start let's do it okay 2010
Pizza John the original well-loved
well-worn classic 2012 green pizza John
neon nineties pizza John eyes eyes eyes
eyes eyes eyes pizza John vampire pizza
John evil pizza John 2013 just the
hoodie 2014 bully Pizza John glowy pizza
John Half Dome pizza john o'b a pizza
John 2015 Warhol John Rainbow Pizza John
our first charity shirt blue neon pizza
John Pisa John misfits Pizza John faux
knitted pizza John sweatshirt nebula
John this year is Hank talked about on
Monday we asked her favorite designers
to design shirts and Rachel is going to
tell you about that so this year we had
a few different artists this one was
designed by a Judy Kaufman this one was
designed by Sarah Samantha's the one
right above me was Julia pot we have
right here which I did we have Big John
pizzeria designed by text we have mint
oil which designed this pretty sweet
indigo one right here and then we have
the design duo rude that defend this one
right here Rachel I hear there's a few
more items in the 2016 pizza miss
collection well yes there are Dave are
those pajama pants you're wearing they
are they're called the PJ PJ and are
they soft they're very soft I think also
talked about Monday we will have the
personal Pizza Pizza miss box which will
contain quite a lot of things that you
can only get in the box it'll have this
hot and fresh shirt a hot fresh notepad
a Pizza John pizza cutter with a bottle
opener an apron with gold imprints and
of course the box so just like last year
we want to have an item that donated is
proceeds to charity this year we have
the pizza John pet leash if you purchase
this pet leash 100% of its profits will
be going to the Animal Legal Defense
Fund you have any questions about the
fund definitely go to the link down
below wait a minute what's that this is
a dftba sock that is only available for
purchase through the dftba awesome socks
club this is the november sack designed
by Rachel and Rachel how many are left
500 that's right
500 more subscriptions are allowed so
buy them soon they're awesome so thanks
for joining us on this tour of the
Pete's in this museum dftba warehouse
will let the professionals take it from
here for gimmick poor face wants to
remind you don't forget to be awesome
and John